boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun very
excited we are still doing interviews at
COFA is the Congress on the future of
engineering software for our second
annual partnership with them we are now
sitting down with Lindell okay hello
hello thank you for coming on to our
show we really appreciate it
thank you for having me I'm excited yay
we are very excited to have Linda on our
show she has 30 years in engineering
software experience she's now the VP of
Product Management at PTC she's very
focused on generative design we're gonna
be talking about this digital
transformation for competitive advantage
and so much more
Linda before we get there let's talk
about you how did you even get involved
in engineering software how did this get
picked up in your life Wow and you know
it's it's I didn't start out expecting
to be in engineering at all and I
originally started just with a passion
for languages and at a certain point
some teacher my calculus teacher
basically said you just have a natural
aptitude for from math and science you
should do something with it and he got
me introduced into a summer program for
Electrical and Computer Engineering and
I hated the electrical but I loved the
computer engineering aspects and so that
was the aha moment to say I need to go
to school and you know focus on the the
computer ultimately computer science
aspects and you know great great time I
actually worked under a professor who
came out of IBM research out of Kipp C
lab and really took me under his wing
and I happened into this thing called C
ad at the time and you know my my first
job was to work with a Russian
mathematician
named puffle rebecky he couldn't write
code but he he could produce these
amazing algorithms for wire harness
bending and it was my job to work with
him to basically translate it into to
something real and I'm he was great to
work with and what really got me hooked
into the engineering space was I was
besides the wire harness I also worked
in graphics and I actually got a defect
from General Motors for a car design
which was about five years before you'd
see it in the market and I just loved
the body style and it was just so
exciting to go I can work in a space
where I get to make a difference and and
work with people who design these these
really cool things yeah that was kind of
the beginning of getting into the
industry shout out to your calculus
teacher because that is a big deal to
have that tiny bit of Mentor help push I
see you have good skills here if you
thought about this go to the summer camp
take these you know though that those
little pushes from from mentors can can
open so many doors for a powerful career
it's so fascinating how important that
is then it's also cool how you you you
know you had these these moments of like
working with that or the Russian
mathematician and just being able to
really kind of like see that you wanted
to be a part of building things into the
world designing things in the world and
so then what about this like these these
milestones that sort of came in your
journey these like aha moments of okay
I'm looking at cad i'm looking at
picking up some of these new skill sets
in engineering software where did you
kind of see things trending towards and
what were what were you achieving in
that process you know it was an
interesting journey along the way and
you know because it was it was a
transformational time going from that
that initial opportunity with computer
vision to the my first startup company
which was PTC or at the time it was
parametric technology corporation and
you know to actually go there that the
industry was transforming in terms of
the actual computer technology of course
Parrott PTC is known for revolutionising
the cat industry with parametric face
modeling at the time I won't be so wise
as to say I understood what we were
doing and how transformational it was
going to be but you know to just be part
of a team to be able to do that and the
the company IP ode and you know and
through that I was in the R&D group just
about parametric based modeling so and
you know being able to to define
features and and to to control you know
control those features with parameters
so you know if you have a height and now
you can just change the height and the
the model readjust readjust interesting
all the other variables will follow suit
it's appropriately appropriately mm-hmm
and and so you know and to expand it to
features and you know I it gives me
pause because it's it's so part of
what computer-aided design is today that
I really have to stop and say what's
parametric because the whole industry
has adopted parametric based design but
you can think about you know you create
drafts and cuts and and slots and all
the the the terminology that is used in
the industry and how to represent those
features and control the features where
prior to that you were talking about
cones and spheres and boolean operations
so a true advancement for sure yeah yeah
okay and then the IPO happened the IPF
happened and you know at the time a
piece ptc continued growth and you know
very successful there at the time in
addition to the the cad system what was
then called PDM product data management
was also coming to the fore because you
create all of these models how do you
how do you manage it change control and
such and so it's the precursor to what
we know as PLM today and while all of
those transitions were happening I got
to a point where there was a realization
of more technology change in the
hardware in the operating systems so at
that point and what was it called I
can't remember Windows came out with
their platform
hmm I forget what it was but basically
there was a transformation moving from
all these unix-based systems to the
Windows platform and with that and some
of us saw that there was an opportunity
to to have a lower cost solution fully
capable of what CAD systems were capable
of at the time but at a much lower price
point at that time than price points
were were probably $70,000 per unit or
higher till you bought your your
hardware license the software and
depending on kind of the extent of
software so very high priced systems and
you know it was a difficult time for for
PTC because how how could you would you
transition from you know a seventy
thousand or a hundred thousand dollar
system to basically were proposing how
do you do something some ten thousand
dollars and then the answer ultimately
was I left there to join the next
startup which was SolidWorks and you
know I was employee number ten and at
SolidWorks working with John Hirschbeck
and you know Mike Payne and company two
to build a parametric based system
it wasn't revolutionary it was really
evolutionary because the the underlying
technology allowed you to build the
system and sell it for $5,000 per seat
and it took a few years until the the
capabilities were advanced enough to
substantially start replacing some of
the larger players and the target really
was small medium-sized companies then in
the course of doing that of course we
were acquired by des Eaux system and you
know that was a big shift for the
industry because of course they had
CATIA so you know how to how to manage
two systems and you know they they did a
very good job about segmenting to
position CATIA for that high-end you
know when you think of aerospace and
some of the high demands and you know
automotive those cars that I love the
body designs and you know very advanced
requirements and SolidWorks was focused
small to medium sized businesses so you
know a good positioning you know across
time probably my my favorite part of
SolidWorks was I had the opportunity to
move to Cambridge England and to
basically build and what was initially
planned to be a new R&D facility for for
the team I was given keys to a house and
and told to go go build it so it's that
startup sort of environment with the the
protection of the umbrella of you know
the parent company Solid Works and
there's a new beautiful place in the
world it was awesome
Cambridge was it was such a wonderful
experience and
and you know to go it literally started
that startup environment
I had a house I had people before I had
an office so the guys would come to the
- to my kitchen table and they they
would work there every day I can imagine
what my neighbors thought you know
because the you know I hadn't really met
them and there are these these men
coming in and out of my house every day
and and you know brought ragers all the
time
yeah so good fun look eight neighbors
we've started a technology company at in
our neighborhood right yeah right you
know these of these bands that come up
and drop you know big boxes of monitors
and that sort of thing so you know very
quickly found found in office for for
the team in Cambridge and spent two
years really building up the the team
focused on the R&D aspects and then
ultimately helping out the the European
group I'll call it secondary he like
marketing support and such so that we
could be a focal point and then
distribute things out to to the rest of
Europe so fabulous fabulous and
opportunity you know to to just grow a
team and the team was was very good very
productive and that tie back to Pavel
where I started a big part of the
responsibility who is routed systems
cabling wire harnessing piping systems
so you know in a sense he came full
circle so so that was awesome so you
were actually a big expander of
SolidWorks into Europe than
location was kind of a funnel of gang
solidworks into more locations in Europe
from the primary focus was was Rd I mean
there there was a whole separate group
you know of course sales and marketing
and such so we were support pre-k Rd of
like the Cambridge intellect into into
what SolidWorks knew how to do right you
know part of it part of the reason to
actually go to Cambridge is not and some
of the the skills that we were looking
for they weren't always easy to find
anywhere in the world and not everybody
believe it or not not everybody wanted
to move to the Boston area yeah right
and you add on top of that the whole
visa issue and you know and trying to
work through I mean the the visa issue
has only gotten worse easier for you to
set up shop there than for them to come
- exactly exactly and you know so and
you know different requirements much
he's here for for Europeans to be moving
around you know the flexibility you so
you don't have to have visa requirements
and you know we had teams from India and
they they could stay longer on you know
just a normal entrance visa as opposed
to having to get the equivalent of like
an h-1b here in the US so you know we
had an Indian group and they would come
spend time to ramp up and learn the
systems and such and we could do that in
the UK easier then trying to get
everybody to Boston so it was really a
need to go find talent and of course
Cambridge is the other
place that you know it depends on who
you talk to where work had actually
started it did start in Boston or did it
start in Cambridge so if you talk to the
people in Cambridge they will say it and
it was founded in in Cambridge if you
talk to people in Boston it was founded
there so interesting if you talk to
people in in Cambridge they say that
Silicon Valley is the the west coast
Cambridge and if you talk to people in
Silicon Valley we say that Cambridge is
the East Coast Silicon Valley there's
this funny jokes because they both very
very powerful centres of of strong right
of technology development yes so so what
was um what was that what was that about
I haven't heard of the Boston versus
Cambridge the debate between where CAD
Wow yeah
now this predates me so I just know more
of the story is there there are people
and you know still around in the
industry who actually lived those times
but there was a place in Cambridge
called the CAD Center and and I believe
it was an offshoot from Cambridge
University but you know don't take that
as fact and and you know so they would
do research around these mechanical type
challenges and that the other aspect is
around the geometric modeling so PTC at
the time we had built our own and
geometry engine the other geometry
engine really came out of Cambridge at
the time so now if you think of Siemens
Siemens has a geometry engine called
para solid came out of Cambridge England
there was also Asus which was created
later than Paris solid but think
fundamentally the same
same core resources available in
Cambridge
so Asus which is actually a Colorado
based company called spatial which was
acquired by des Howe they had they had
their origins in Cambridge England as
well so when you think of you know
really the geometry engine is the heart
of a CAD system you had you know what's
now called granite part of PTC was built
in in Boston but precursors to that were
were built in Cambridge so this
knowledge this technology you know on
the Boston side there there was computer
vision prime technology you know they
were kind of the companies that started
in Boston about the same time as the CAD
Center was happening in the UK hence the
competing yes yeah
but those all predate me this is this is
always it's always an interesting
thinking about which areas of the world
are innovating concurrently out on
similar edge science or technology and
and who's and who's bringing forth who
claims kind of like crisper cast 9 to a
little bit of like you know there's
always interesting things like that all
right now what about post SolidWorks up
until PTC most recently so post
SolidWorks and I hadn't had worked for a
company at the time that was called
raindrop Geomagic
more commonly known as Geomagic ping Fuu
who is well known in the industry had
headed up that company so I had worked
with ping in in North Carolina for for a
while and and from from the air
I had actually moved to spatial
technology which is component based
software selling software components
and of course selling ASIS which is why
I know Asus so well and that's what
moved me to Colorado because that's
where the company was based and I came
with the deso acquisition of spatial so
des Eaux had recruited me back - it was
actually a shift for me because up and
up until that point my primary function
was always hardy with spatial I actually
transitioned over into sales and
marketing yeah and you know a lot of
people go well why didn't know why did
you make the job and what was what was
easy natural was because it was software
components that were selling so who are
we selling to or selling to heads of our
need to help them solve their problems
so I can speak their language I
understand their problems and you know
having been at SolidWorks licensing Pera
solid I was a consumer of component
technology so you know I just flipped
sides in in the conversation so it was
very easy to transition that's own so
that's another one of the recurring
themes of conversations that from the
interviews that we've had is to be able
to have both the technical understanding
and a business understanding I want to
build rapport and know how do I get into
technical details all right that's such
an important mm-hmm building right right
and it's I mean it was a great learning
ground you know especially the the sales
aspects you know because there's there's
creativity in in software there's a
different creativity in sales
interesting and you know to kind of
learn the the standard phrase
out-of-the-box thinking right Brooke we
encourage everybody to think out of the
box it's kind of an old phrase now but I
found I was trying to put the
salespeople back in the box
help me think so
you know it was it was great learning
great opportunity and I actually left
the industry for her for a while and
branched out
we're just surfing somewhere no oh not
quite and you know but I I and I can
honestly say at that point I was still a
startup junkie
you know spatial and while while I was
there the first time around and I was
that spatial twice the first time around
it was about taking the the company back
to profitability and you know
stabilizing Asus and you know because
the company was struggling which allowed
the opportunity for the acquisition so
to to do the culture change you know the
technology writing it holding on to the
customers while you're going through
that transition you know fascinating
challenge is definitely the hardest job
I've ever had
you know startups like like Solid Works
so rewarding hard work but when you're
trying to change culture you know it's
it's one of the hardest jobs I've ever
had and most rewarding yes yes you know
when you see this and when you can see
people recognize that they're successful
yeah thanks to your real hardcore hustle
along with so many other people thanks
of building out tools and getting them
out to the right people and them smiling
when they use it yeah this is this is
very important right so how about the
the this this massive digital
transformation for competitive advantage
this is you know PTC's tagline and I
mean there is a massive digital
transformation happening with
engineering software but it is in many
ways it does end up giving the ones that
the ones that take on these the
engineering software tools that are at
the edge that are at the newest that are
the ones that are providing the most
value they're the ones that then gain
the advantage
over in terms of how fast they can
iterate on creativity how well the their
their their designs function um in the
world so so teach us about what it's
been like being a part of this of the
culture that is that is PTC so you know
to be fair and I haven't been back at
PTC for for very long so you know in
terms of the culture so far I didn't I
love what what I'm experiencing you know
very high energy and and to see the the
breadth of of the portfolio you know
being traditionally more in that cad PLM
sort of space with spatial i used to see
a wide variety of technology offerings
but to see ptc really taking it with vr
ER and in IOT and I'll say stretching
and and being able to to provide
solutions on the edge while still having
that core based in you know the CAD PLM
space it's as as I'm learning more about
how all the systems are connected it's
it's fascinating and I am so impressed
with what they've been able to to
accomplish and because yeah it's I'll
just leave it at that
you know I'm learning about what
especially the IOT is is an area that
I'm very interested in relative to
generative design because of course my
coming to PTC is through the frustum
acquisition so for for us
generative design is is a paradigm shift
for the industry where we're still in
its infancy
there's
still a long way to go - to get to the
full value for engineering for engineers
but you know I can see the potential as
you look at the information that's going
to be available from you know be it IOT
or as the the PLM systems are capturing
data and part of generative is how can
we leverage AI or machine learning you
know trying to to get clarity of what
would be then the opportunities and the
specific technologies that we need to
use to be able to leverage all of that
information in order to better inform
your designs yes yes yes it's almost as
though the the human capability to run
all of the permutations on what would be
the optimal function given a certain
amount of specifications is just it's
just it's nowhere near the capacity of a
eyes ability to to do that so sure so -
to now be able to leverage generative
design just there's a rerun all of the
possibilities given the parameters that
we have what is the optimal function and
what does it look like and that and then
you know what would it be like to
manufacture that we're we need a source
the materials from it's just it ends up
being a very interesting part of the
future generator design out of
manufacturing it just seems like a and
it's just like a general intelligence
constantly being able to iterate on
itself which is which is exciting in
many ways I'm ready for Star Trek I'm
very I'm very very ready but the one
thing to keep in mind is it's it's not
just about things like additive
manufacturing and
you know this is it's applicable for the
manufacturing processes you know that
the traditional ones casting forging you
know milling all of those so that the
generative process can can provide that
the options the key part which I think
you said is optimal solutions because
it's it's great the technology is out
there now so you have the compute
resources you know you have the storage
resources all of that sort of stuff it's
becoming less and less expensive to
leverage all of that but in the end what
you need are the optimal designs so
there's little value to throw ten
thousand options at an engineer and say
which ones would you like and the other
challenge is as you set up the problems
and - and we we still have to answer how
to properly set up the problem because
you can solve it all solved successfully
but if you didn't set it up properly
your your system is going to fail and as
you test it further downstream so on you
know that's why I say there's still
there's still a lot to learn and a key
part as we look at it is you know we we
need to make sure that the human is
still the driver in the process so it's
great we have some autonomous
computations happening but the feedback
is hugely important to say is it headed
where I expect it to go can I change in
the midst of this you know in order to
refine my solution and so on and of
course as we go through the whole
generative process you get to you know
offer up here's your three four six ten
optimal solutions
now what do you do with that and you
know that's that's where if I look at
PTC's portfolio especially around the
cat's base and their partnership with
with the incest to to take the
information and then take it back into
the workflow so that they can be looking
at the the simulation live and do that
validation and ultimately final analysis
type validation you know to to say yes
yes our optimal choices are meeting all
of the criteria so general gets you
there faster but you can't skip those
steps it's still hugely important yeah
and to follow all of those those other
steps teach us about the order of
operations here so does that do that do
we get the ten generative designs first
and then we go through the ANSYS
simulation live and then we get
validated is that the order right okay
so then the simulation live tests the
ten generative designs right for
functionality for really forces sure
yeah okay its ability to perform as it
yeah as we right there and you may
choose just to have one versus the ten
and you know that's where we leave it up
to the engineer what they do initial
exploration in in the generative process
and ultimately they're there they're
trying to drive to the one solution so I
mean would I expect them to take ten
maybe not you know maybe two or three
into the simulation live
and you know to continue with their
validation and go downstream from there
mm-hmm
so this is so interesting because if the
if the if the how does how does the
generative designs how do they get
entered into the answer simulation live
like I'm very interested in how it kind
of like ports over and how it you know
runs that simulation how does it like
how does it compute that so I mean
that's a that's a big part of what we're
working through right now if you look at
generative systems today and this
includes frustum you know at the point
of the acquisition we were all
independent tools and one of the
barriers to adoption is how do you plug
back into the ecosystem on the front end
and the back end right so how do you
take your your cad model be it a part or
an assembly sub assembly who would ever
bring it into the system that first part
is is fairly straightforward you know
and the CAD systems and the industry can
has that figured out and we can figure
out how to bring all of that information
in you know so now when you do your
design space exploration and you're
setting up your loads and constraints
and and so on you solve and you have
something which is not not geometrically
compatible with any of the traditional
cad systems so part of the challenge is
for us to figure out how to have then
the generative representation
it's it's more than coexist but how to
integrate it back into the workflows and
you know and it's it is one of those
barriers to adoption and you know one of
them that you know of course we have to
to work with the the rest of the team
within PTC to to solve that problem
because ideally you don't want to have
to take the model if if we solve the
geometry parts which is a complex
problem and you still want to be able to
not have to set up your problem all over
again as you take it into discovery life
right so how can we make it a seamless
experience for for for the user and and
you know while well that's the the view
as I see it of of what we need to
accomplish inside of PTC for any system
to be successful they have to be able to
to solve that compatibility problem and
you know it's no different than well
even even external systems and you know
you have to develop that integration so
if if you're a and on shape how how does
on shape plug into a downstream analysis
there is some sort of integration that
that has to happen and the more seamless
you can make that the better the
experience for the user
yeah yeah yeah mmm the more frictionless
the user experiences and the more it
enables maximal creativity for
engineering that this is gonna be on
leak a lot unlocking a lot of creative
potential who are the most common users
right now because we know a lot of like
FIRST Robotics kids are using PTC
who are the most we're the most common
use cases right now for for both the
generative design as well as the answer
simulation live which
um I mean I I can't really say for the
an sessom elation life you know because
this goes to you know my my knowledge
coming into you know into the the group
but from from a generative perspective
there's there's actually been a
challenge for generative because if you
look at the industry there they're just
go look at a set of websites and various
companies will have this what is
generative design and the definitions
are all over the map and you know
generative design is topology
optimization generative design his
genetic algorithms generative design is
fully autonomous so you know the first
question is what is generative design
and you know it's it's still something
that means clarification there's a and I
look at it as there's there's
generations or steps to generative
design where you have something like
topology optimization it's a tool that
generative utilizes in order to provide
results you know there are people who
think generative is only for additive
mmm-hmm because of course the lattice
structures and even with your topology
optimization you can get those those
star Trak kind of shapes you know this
based future shapes and or the whole
lattice structure so by by associativity
people think that's what generative is
for and additive is just one possible
manufacturing process that you know
generative can provide solutions for it
comes back to you you can do the casting
milling forging and so on
so if if I look at you know
pre-acquisition who the early adopters
were primary interest was around lattice
structures and it's the research groups
in engineering organizations who are
trying to figure out how did they get a
lighter-weight the material science
right
and so how it's it's the research
organizations to try and learn and
understand what can they do you know be
it with the the new materials you know
you think of like an Airbus for example
Airbus ge they're the the companies that
are at the forefront in the news around
additive and so they they do rely on
generative in order to help provide
solutions for them but we come back to
we have other opportunities where it's
basic they have a manufacturing problem
they need to solve so and you know an
interesting aspect is to think about say
costing you know I need to to build my
widget whatever that widget is and you
know I have different material options I
may have only certain you know machine
options so those are variables that I
want to take a look at to figure out how
do I get the most cost effective and
okay maybe I want then I want to use the
least amount of material so what are
those constraints that you want to put
into the system in order to produce the
optimal design so generative and this is
why it's so transformational as as we
work through on this whole variety of
use cases it will allow
and the user to again figure out optimal
designs based on what they what they
have what they know so it's not just
about the loot the loads that you put on
it it long-term as as generative comes
to its it's more mature state and you
can then say I only have these materials
you know I want the lowest cost and and
so on so it it's part of the design
process you know it's important that
that the way that you're you know
identifying that it's such an early time
in the in the definitions that we are a
little all over the place and that soon
it'll maybe all of them will kind of all
the definitions what kind of bundled
together into into a one that that
encompasses that but the the enhanced
creative experience with general design
in the way you're describing it it's
just it's it's of me it's a massive part
of engineering software now will you
speak to where you feel as though so
much of the engineering software trends
are pointing towards hmm there's Perry
Hughes trends you know it's being being
here at Co Fez and the the digital twin
is
you know is that or the digital thread I
should say you know is it seems to be
the all-encompassing targets for for
companies and so that would mean a
digital thread would mean so the the
well honestly I'll say that's that's
part of the challenge yeah you know what
is the definition of digital thread just
like what is the definition of
generative design the digital thread and
again it's like calm it's like combining
everything that's being discussed at Ko
Fez into one thing it seems that way it
seems yeah you know so how do you how do
you take that the advances that are
happening and you know how do you as as
you're going through say the entire
lifecycle process you know how how does
PLM evolve to relate to it and you know
of course as I look at that the IOT you
know all of that information and you
know the performance information how
does that type back into the the digital
threat yeah so yeah it's and they are
right there's so many of these of these
components and simulations and then what
would you say is a main principle or
skill that we should have children
and adults develop into the 21st century
hmm just one skill hmm that's a
fantastic question
I mean I I start in our inherent nature
has to first be an inquisitive
continuous learning and it sits at the
foundation and you know so from from the
air yes and you know the sciences are so
important and you know as as my children
have grown and you know they they all
had the the computer programming courses
and you know my my daughter and she is
she does art animation and she kept
saying why do I need that there are
people who who do the coding I just want
to use the solution it's like no you
know if you have that basic
understanding imagine how you can
influence control and so many of the
software solutions or your phone apps
and you know you can change them if you
have those basic concepts and so you
don't have to be the the power developer
you don't have to be the power
mathematician but these you know to have
that firm foundation across the sciences
and just helps you as you're interfacing
because and if I take it out of this
space we're touching digital everywhere
so you know it is just part of our life
and be its and you know trying to trying
to work your cell phone somebody trying
to tune in the basketball game humor
from from yesterday you you have to know
and have a basic comfort with the the
technologies that are there
and so it just becomes foundational and
it doesn't matter that you're an artist
versus an engineer but a basic
foundational understanding it kind of
reminds me a lot of this base camp of
knowledge that it's something we're
really aiming to try and make more
common in our and our culture is to get
people to the business base camp
understanding of what's happening where
we came from what you know who we are
where we're planning to go how we get
there how we problems to solve and then
rock it out to the edge if you want
which edge do you want to go through of
knowledge how do you know you know so so
dude we cover everything well do you
feel like there's something else that
you would like to maybe end with
discussing or do we wrap pretty well you
know I figured yeah I feel covered a lot
wonderful wonderful this is great this
is such a pleasure thank you so much for
joining us on the show thank you yeah
pleasure there's a lot to still to
understand and and I'm really grateful
that you were able to drop these these
these powerful wisdoms on us about about
what's going on in the industry and
where we're heading thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you're thinking go and share
these wisdoms around with your
communities with your families your
friends online go and share them around
also check out Linda's links below check
out the links to Kofi's below as well
check out simulations links below as
well support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in help
us scale help us grow and go and build
the future manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
peace